So the question was, does ConferenceForm have properties that
map to these properties in conference? Yes, the conference
form has a name property. The user's going to enter
the name of the conference when they create a
conference. And again, it has a topics property, because
the user's going to enter the topics when they create
the conference. But no, ConferenceForm doesn't have a property
for profile key. The profile key's going to be calculated based
on the profile that's the ancestor of the conference. And also
no, it doesn't have a month property, because the user doesn't
enter the month, they just enter a start date. And then
the conference constructor actually calculates the
month, based on the start date.